AT THIS HOUR A MANHUNT IS UNDER
WAY IN CANADA FOR TWO SUSPECTS
IN A STABBING SPREE THAT LEFT
TEN PEOPLE DEAD AND 15 OTHERS
INJURED.
THE ROYAL CANADIAN MOUNTED
POLICE SAY THE ATTACKS WERE
SPREAD OUT ACROSS 13 DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS.
THEY CENTERED AROUND AN
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY AND A
NEARBY VILLAGE IN SASKATCHEWAN.
RIGHT NOW POLICE SAY THE MOTIVE
IS NOT NOPE, BUT THEY BELIEVE
SOME OF THE VICTIMS WERE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED WHILE
OTHERS WERE RANDOM.
POLICE HAVE NAMED THE TWO
SUSPECTS.
HERE THEY ARE, 31-YEAR-OLD
DAMION SANDERSON AND 30-YEAR-OLD
MILES SANDERSON.
THEY ARE BELIEVED TO BE
TRAVELING IN A BLAKNEY SAN
ROGUE, -- BLACK NISSAN ROGUE BUT
IT'S MIDDLE EAST THEY COULD HAVE
CHANGED VEHICLES.
LET'S GO STRAIGHT TO PAULA
NEWTON IN CANADA.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING, PAULA?
>> Reporter: THE NEWS IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF HOURS, AGAIN,
THAT THESE TWO SUSPECTS,
INCREDIBLY SUSPECTS REMAIN AT
LARGE AND THAT'S QUITE
CONCERNING AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
THE LAST KNOWN SIGHTING POLICE
BELIEVE WAS IN REGINA,
SASKATCHEWAN, ABOUT A THREE AND
A HALF HOUR DRIVE FROM THESE
COMMUNITIES, AND THEY BELIEVE
THEY WERE LAST SEEP AROUND
MIDDAY YESTERDAY.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN NOW THOUGH
TO THE POLICE CHIEF FROM REGINA
TALKING ABOUT HOW SO MANY MORE
TIPS FROM THE PUBLIC ARE NEEDED
IF THEY ARE TO CATCH THESE
SUSPECTS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE KNOW, WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT SOMEONE OUT THERE KNOWS THE
WHEREABOUTS OF THESE TWO AND HAS
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
VALUABLE TO THE POLICE, AND I
URGE YOU TO GET IN TOUCH WITH
YOUR LOCAL POLICE SERVICE TO LET
US KNOW.
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, WHAT'S
DISTURBING ABOUT THIS, BORIS, IS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS BASICALLY
SWARMED TO THE AREA, AND THEY
ARE GETTING HELP FROM ALL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT, STILL THEY HAVE
NOT FOUND THESE SUBJECTS.
NOW, THE COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES,
AS YOU SAID, 13 SEPARATE CRIME
SCENES SO FAR, 10 DEAD, MORE
THAN A DOZEN INJURED.
PEOPLE ARE WONDERING NOW IF
THERE ARE STILL OTHER VICTIMS
OUT THERE, BORIS, THAT MAY HAVE
SOUGHT OUT MEDICAL HELP IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
THEY ALSO WANT THEM TO GO AND
COME FORWARD.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THE
PRIME MINISTER HERE, JUSTIN
TRUDEAU, PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT
LATE LAST NIGHT SAYING I'M
SHOCKED AND DEVASTATED BY THE
HORRIFIC ATTACK IN JAMES SMITH
CREE NATION AND WALDON,
SASKATCHEWAN THAT CLAIMED THE
LIVES OF STEP PEOPLE AND INJURED
MANY MORE.
AS CANADIANS WE MOURN WITH
EVERYONE AFFECTED BY THE TRAGIC
VIOLENCE AND WITH THE PEOPLE OF
SASKATCHEWAN.
BORIS, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
ALREADY, I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE WITH SOME PEOPLE IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
EVERYONE HAS DECLINED COMMENT.
YOU CAN REAL FEEL THE GRAVITY OF
THESE' V EVENTS, THE VIOLENCE O
IT, AND THE FACT THAT IT MAY
HAVE AFFECTED PEOPLE FROM THE
SAME FAMILIES AND SAME
COMMUNITIES.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WATCH THIS.
WE ARE EXPECTING, HOPEFULLY,
ANOTHER UPDATE FROM POLICE
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW HOURS.
BORIS?
>> WE KNOW YOU'LL KEEP WATCHING
THE STORY CLOSELY FOR US.
PAULA NEWTON FROM OTTAWA, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING US TO JOIN US WITH
THE LATEST IS JULIA KIAM, A
FORMER ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AND ALSO WITH US CNN
SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST
CHARLES RAMSEY, THE FORMER
PHILADELPHIA POLICE
SUPERI
SUPERINTENDENT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN SASKATCHEWAN?
>> WE KNOW THAT THE INDIGENOUS
NATION, THE JAMES SMITH CREE
NATION WENT UNDER LOCKDOWN.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE IS A STRONG EVIDENCE THAT
A CERTAIN COMMUNITY WAS
TARGETED, BUT THEN IF YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE BREADTH OF KILLINGS
OVER SUCH A SORT A LONG STRETCH
OF GEOGRAPHY, ONE HAS TO ASSUME
THAT THERE MIGHT BE JUST ALSO
RANDOM VIOLENCE INVOLVED, SO IT
STARTS AS TARGETED AND BECOMES A
SPREE.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW YET.
I THINK THE OTHER THING I'M SORT
OF SURPRISED AT IS THAT THEY ARE
STILL IN PURSUIT.
I WOULD HAVE ASSUMED JUST GIVEN
THE NUMBER OF RESOURCES, YOU
KNOW, HEADED TOWARDS THAT AREA.
THEY KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND HAVE
SOME IDENTIFICATION OF A CAR AND
IT WILL THEY FIND THEM THEY NOTE
KNOW WHETHER THEY WILL BE AT
EASE.
>> JULIETTE BRINGS UP A GOOD
POINT.
THE AREA THAT POLICE ARE
CANVASSING IS ENORMOUS.
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT BRINGS US.
>> YES.
IT'S AN ENORMOUS AND REMOTE
AREA, AT LEAST THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING, WHICH MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT.
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME THAT THEY
KNOW THE LAND SCAUP SO THERE ARE
PROBABLY A LOT OF PLACES THAT
THEY COULD HIDE.
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ASKING
FOR THE PUBLIC'S HELP.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO KNOW THEM,
THAT PERHAPS KNOW AREAS THAT
THEY TENDED TO HANG OUT IN, AND
SO FORTH, AND THAT'S WHAT THE
POLICE ARE DOING NOW, IS THEY
ARE ACTUALLY SEARCHING
EVERYTHING.
THIS IS A SEARCHED OVERNIGHT AND
WERE PROBABLY USING THERMAL
IMAGING DEVICES, ANYTHING THEY
COULD POSSIBLY USE TO FIND THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PROBABLY IN
HIDING RIGHT NOW.
>> CHIEF RAMSEY, THERE'S ALSO A
CHALLENGE IN PROCESSING 13
DIFFERENT GRIME SCENES.
WHAT'S THAT LIKE?
>> 13 DIFFERENT CRIME SCENES.
EACH ONE REQUIRES PROTECTION.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT THE CRIME
SCENE AND YOU HAVE TO PROCESS
THE SCENE.
THAT IS UNUSUAL.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS THAT'S
VERY UNUSUAL FOR US IN AMERICA
IS THE FACT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MASS STABBINGS HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> USUALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MASS SHOOTINGS SO THIS IS QUITE
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
BEING USED TO COMMIT THESE
PARTICULAR CRIMES, BUT, AGAIN,
IT'S A CHALLENGE ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
AT THE SAME TIME THEY ARE TRYING
TO FIND THESE FOLKS, THERE ARE
OTHER OFFICERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
THERE PROCESSING SCENES.
THEY ARE ALSO INTERVIEWING
WITNESSES, INTERVIEWING FAMILY,
PROBABLY EXECUTING SEARCH
WARRANTS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
>> JULIETTE, THE FACT THAT IT
WAS A MASS STABBING, THAT'S AN
UNCOMMON CRIME.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THE NATURE PERHAPS OF THE MOTIVE
IF YOU COULD SPECULATE ON THAT?
>> SO, I THINK IT HAS MORE TO DO
WITH ACCESS IN SOME WAYS, IN
EACH COUNTRY IT'S HORRIBLE TO
SAY, BUT EACH COUNTRY SORT OF
HAS THEIR MASS MURDER WEAPONRY,
AND IN CASES, COUNTRIES WHERE
IT'S NOT VERY EASY TO GET GUNS,
WE'VE SEEN STABBINGS BEFORE.
WE'VE SEEN THEM IN EUROPE AND IN
OTHER AREAS, SO THAT MAY BE ONE
EXPLANATION.
THE OTHER IS, OF COURSE, THEIR
DESIRE, THAT THEY ACTUALLY
WANTED THIS KIND OF KILLING FOR
WHATEVER REASON, AND THAT'S
WHERE THE MOTIVE COMES INTO
PLAY.
ARE THEY PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERTS
IN GUNS OR KNIFINGS OR
STABBINGS, PEOPLE WHO SORT OF AN
OBSESSION WITH GUNS AND STORES?
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
NIGHTS THEY ARE.
THIS IS THE CHALLENGE, SO IN --
IN SUDDEN CRISES LIKE A MASS
SHOOTING THAT CHUCK AND I ARE
ON, CHIEF RAMSEY AND I ARE ON
ALL THE TIME ABOUT, YOU SORT OF
KNOW WHAT YOUR POOL OF VICTIMS
IS BECAUSE IT'S A LIMITED AREA
AND IT HAPPENS SO FAST.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS SORT
OF A SLOW ROLL KILLING, AND I
THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT, AND AS
PAULA WAS SAYING, WE ACTUALLY --
IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT THERE
MIGHT BE OTHERS WHO WERE VICTIMS
WHO GO TO LOCAL AREAS.
THEY ARE NOT IDENTIFIED AS PART
OF THE POOL BECAUSE IT --
BECAUSE THE POOL IS SO BIG OR
THE GEOGRAPHIC AREA IS SO BIG,
AND THIS OFF HAPPENS WHERE WE
MAY FIND OVER THE NEXT 24, 48
HOURS OTHER INSTANCES OR
ATTEMPTS, AND THAT MAY BE
HELPFUL ACTUALLY IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING, IN TERMS OF
CAPTURING THESE GUYS EVENTUALLY,
BUT, LOOK, UNTIL THEY ARE
CAPTURED, THIS IS A REALLY
STRESSFUL SITUATION FOR PEOPLE
IN THE AREA AND CERTAINLY IF
THEY GOT INTO A CAR OF PEOPLE
WHO -- WHO MIGHT ENGAGE OR
ENCOUNTER THEM.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A STORY WE'RE
FOLLOWING VERY CLOSELY SO
JULIETTE KAYYEM AND CHARLES
RAMSEY, HOPE YOU DON'T GO TOO
FAR IN CASE WE NEED YOUR
UPDATES.
THANKS SO MUCH